[Music]
by the way
you said you want to do five minutes of
material is that true maybe
maybe
i have to think
whoa
i i have to think about what joke i want
to do
you've always said no it's flat out
straight after that
but we'll see
thinking about doing like a like a
combination about the
the like my perspective of
well
i mean i guess i actually shouldn't do
that because it's already
what because i'm thinking like
you know i was going to combine
my
unfortunate memories of walking in on
you and mom
great that's great joke but like the
first one and then what the second one
is but like the first one there's like a
punchline in it and the second one i
don't understand what you mean the first
one second one like like the first
experience
when i was very young
i know i don't remember i'm just
stealing mostly from your joke yes and
then the second time
well you i would just do what you
remember
i wouldn't do the one you don't remember
because you're gonna end up
dipping into
you don't want it to sound like my
material
right
that's what i'm afraid of yeah and so
you want to stick with
your
recollections
and i i think
but by the way no pressure man to do
i'm surprised to hear you say it yeah i
was surprised i even thought about it
because you've always been so adamant
like you don't want to do stand-up
this doesn't mean i want to do stand up
right you might just want to do five
minutes just explore
i would be 100 in favor
of you trying it you know i'm i think
everybody should try everything
it right matter if it's not ringing off
[Music]
[Music]
wow